you know I'm driving in and I hear John
Montone Mike Mont owns dad on 1010 wins
and he's at a basketball court and he's
reporting on a 14 year old who was shot
and killed and what a tragic thing it
was and it was like a stray bullet and
it hit the fourteen-year-old in the neck
and he's going who dreamed suddenly
dashed and you're just like oh this is
such a serious terrible story thank god
there's a newsman like John Montone to
cover it and then I get in here and I'm
like okay Mike Montone the younger
Montone what do we have and he's like
why was at the porn Expo weekend so
you've got coverage from the porn Expo
oh good
good that's great I will take I will
take pornography over gang violence any
day Sam Roberts that's right but you do
it the same this thing you got that same
voice right but but different coverage
different beats well I have to bring an
air of legitimacy to the smut industry
that's right you took what your family
has taught you news reporting and what
your own passion has brought you
pornography and you brought them
together you went to the exotica Expo
with handsome Rob and baby Frankie our
intern and the exotica Expo is one of
the premier pornography conventions it's
like comic-con but for porn so people go
they can buy their sex toys they can
meet their favorite porn stars get
pictures with them do the whole thing
and and you want to check it out
is that correct yes we did so what was
it is there an angle we should know
about for this or what the beat was or
should we just should just see how this
one well I was hoping a gym would be or
unfortunately he is at because this is a
subject he has awaited not actually
everyone on the staff is actually kind
of waited on this one so we we went out
hoping to settle a debate that has been
raging on the gym and samjoe since since
before I came aboard have you believe
first of all I love the debate do you
eat ask we're talking to a guy now the
first couple when they were a couple I
believe them I think they you know go
home and they perform analingus you know
on each other to their heart's content
we can jump into those two after the
fact we we did a little deeper dive on
that couple this guy is wearing a
Superman t-shirt leather jacket very
very sweaty black gentleman black
gentleman I don't I don't believe a word
he's saying right now I do not either
because he said like because Mike asked
him if you eat ass and he said hey you
know I have you know I used to yeah I'm
like okay you're adding a lot of words
to that that's a pretty simple yes-or-no
question yeah well he lets us know how
it went down give him give him a chance
to explain all right
cross that boundary
she kept eat my ass eat my ass yeah how
do you say no to that exactly so you ate
her ass how did you end up in here well
she just kept saying you know eat my ass
eat no that didn't that didn't happen I
don't think at all
you have no desire to eat ass no we've
already been over it like I don't know
how many times but you hear people
talking about you're like well it must
be a lot of fun if people are eating it
now people can do what people are gonna
do it's like I should have tried it once
no I'm not that tight I'm not sit there
and go oh he's having fun I want to do
what he's doing like I have plenty of
fun what do you see you know and porn
when you see it all on display right the
whole thing no I don't I don't not like
I want to dive into that whole area no I
have it I'm not so broken that I'm
searching for the next thing in the next
thing and go like okay I need to I need
people to now open up and show me the
insides of their body on pornography
yeah I think it's just you know
exploration is a fun thing you like
exploration yeah okay like that fun
let's look at this guy let's see if he
likes to have fun at the bottom feel the
pulse of the people and find out if if
America is an AFC tan country
America maybe but I'm not hey is it that
you
you find so objectionable about having
your salad tossed
I have Crohn's disease
Mike you know what happens with Crohn's
disease oh yeah yeah that's not good you
don't want to eat the ass of someone
with Crohn's disease now I'd be like
eating Hornswoggle ass plate a mouthful
yeah IBS to the umpteenth degree a lot
of activity going on back there
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app
[Music]